TV is about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm pissed working on censor tonight the
geriatric generation who just won't quit
the top us Republican terrified
supporters by corpsing mid-speech as two
political antiques prepare to buy it
again for the presidency should top
political jobs have an age limit or
debate
so tonight critical race Theory reaches
schools in Britain should children be
taught that everything is racially
biased that's the most bizarre Tick-Tock
Trend yet performers raking thousands
for pretending to be computer characters
is this the Vanguard of contemporary
creativity or is Tick Tock rotting our
young brains to digital Darlings will
Jewel it out
foreign
[Music]
s on the planet are probably President
Joe Biden and rock legend Mick Jagger
you can judge for yourself which one of
them is wearing their years with more
Panache and for that matter which one of
them is better suited so perhaps being
leader of the Free World one looks like
he's never slept and doesn't need to the
other is usually asleep one Can't Get No
Satisfaction the other well let's be
honest you better get up the stairs but
as Mick Jagger and icon of Britain turns
80. it's worth reflecting on the man and
myth who's become a medical and cultural
Marvel here he is still an action
[Music]
thank you
I like that yeah
that guy is 80 years old staggering
after a lifetime of hard partying
endless world tours a lot of drugs he
still dances like a teenager still dates
incredibly beautiful women they're still
raising a six-year-old son he might just
be the goat of 80 year olds and the
serious Point here is as Western
societies do get older we're having a
lot more debate about aging compare the
flexing thrusting Vitality of Mick
Jagger to Mitch McConnell just one year
older who leads to Republicans in the
United States Senate yesterday mid
through a speech to journalists this
happened
after some cooperation
and a string of
Indians
anything else you want to say I'm sure
let's go back to it
do you want to say anything else to the
Press
that is a hard watch does that man look
capable of being one of the most
powerful men in American politics there
are actually many people understanding
me was that Mitch McConnell looks like a
walking advertisement for age limits on
politicians well today Dianne Feinstein
a 90 year old Senator with whom I've had
many dealings I think she's been a
remarkable contributor to American
political life but had to be physically
prodded to vote again it's painful to
watch
admitted
yeah just say hi okay just
fine thank you
because we have our own examples in our
own decrepit House of Lords over here
The Front Runners for the next U.S
presidential election at age 77 and 80.
Joe Biden would be 86 at the end of his
second term it's just increasingly
implausible and he gets a hard time for
his age because he does things well like
this
thank you
all right God Save the Queen man
[Applause]
[Music]
but maybe aging itself is not the
problem after all we're all doing it as
Bill Maher often says ageism could be
the last acceptable Prejudice perhaps
we've forgotten that some of our elderly
are actually also some of our wisest
it doesn't matter to me I feel like this
is a Prejudice that this country has
this ageism it's a it's an individual
thing to be president you're the Elder
every civilization seems to understood
this the Elder we go to you for advice
and wisdom I just think it's a narrative
that oh he looks old he's he looks like
the same guy I've ever seen he's a
little older so he fell off his bike and
you mentioned Trump's fat ass even being
on a bike
he's got a point aging is all relative
Jane Fonda looks 50. Sam Smith also
looks 50. Joan Collins is 90 but she's
feisted almost anyone I know and looks
about 30. it's not the age that's the
problem it's the way you are with your
age if I'm anything like Mick Jagger at
80 I'll be pretty satisfied I think I've
got a pretty good chance to be honest
we're both big Arsenal fans
we both identify as deals I didn't put
that line in by the way that's just
because I'm going off today we both give
ourselves at the very peak of physical
Perfection and we're both of course
utterly irresistible to not just women
but to non-binaries as well uh he used
to rock and roll frontman what I am to
broadcasting at least I look in the
mirror and say that to myself every
morning even if nobody else does so here
are to many more years of simik and me
but there is a debate isn't that about
Age and what you do with your age so
joining me now to make some sense of
this uh making her uncensored debut is
journalists and Sky News Australia
presenter Jenna Clark welcome thank you
for having me normally talk civilly to
Australians during a national series I'm
making it a rare exception for you
political Journey saver Santina and form
MEP and father of Boris Johnson Stanley
Johnson okay well welcome to all of you
Stanley full declaration time how old
are you currently identifying as well I
am 80
82 I'm coming up for 83. so you're in
the perfect will wheelhouse here because
you're a bit older than Joe Biden you're
a year older than Mitch McConnell we
just saw Corps sing Vanilli half a
minute
um but you're also two three years older
than Mick Jagger so what is it about age
does age as a number matter or is it
really what's still going on here and
your basic physical mobility and mental
capability
well you can't ignore the physical
capability side I've been pretty lucky
on that on that front I've just done
eight weeks in China it's been fairly
you know fairly tough going from time to
time but you can't ignore the physical
some but I think you're absolutely right
it is the mental stuff which is by far
the most important we have had people of
my age and much more who've had major
major political gods and and carried
them on I mean think about I think I
don't know who has got Germany out of
the mess of the second world war
Churchill was 65 when he became prime
minister actually for the for the first
time
bathroom heaven knows I think
Gladstone's lost Administration he was
well over and we had it right we have
had much younger politicians running the
country who've made a right right pick
zero vist only haven't we so I'm not
going down that route I'm already I'm
yanking you wait my point really is this
it is not in his question for actually
having the body you need the body you
know the body is not 100 essential think
about it Roosevelt Roosevelt but I mean
but it's the mind and I agree it's not
just the mind but it's also the mindset
this is what I'm getting at because you
see you can think old and you can think
old you're not necessarily going to take
the right political decision because
actually right so all right Jenna I
think the thing for me about this is Joe
Biden is the most powerful man in the
world yeah he's the president of the
United States this is probably the
toughest gig out there for anyone let
alone someone who's 80. let alone
someone who by Common agreement is
showing signs of genuine senility
perhaps even mild dementia yeah I
absolutely agree and I think of what
we're seeing in Mr Biden is absolutely
horrific to watch him decline right in
front of our eyes considering but it
almost feels like the Democrats have no
one else and that is such a blight on
that party in itself but the fact is I'd
love uh President Biden to hang around
but I don't think he belongs in the
white house I think that's I mean
you know you look at it it's
uncomfortable it's uncomfortable
watching Biden making all these verbal
gas you know saying God saved the queen
when she's been dead nine months he was
at a funeral falling over Mitch
McConnell freezing dying financially
having to be shown how to vote this is
one of the top senators in American
history just completely incapable of
even knowing how to vote now it can't be
right for the for the electorate of
these countries yeah well I mean
speaking exclusively about Mitch
McConnell I think you know I mean that's
it's sort of a man that feels is holding
the position is a man that probably who
should step aside and get out the way
yeah I mean there's even a law in place
that if he does feel he can't finish the
term then a Democrat can appoint another
Republican to stand in from him I mean
you know when you've got that kind of
contingency plan in place you sort of
think well why is he there in the first
place I mean we've got the cricket game
are we going to come to this by the way
obviously but um Jimmy Anderson's 41 is
considered to be over the hill too old
give it up Jimmy he's 41 he's half
Biden's age and still bowling metronome
and the Aussie still can't get him away
so I'm just not convinced that really
the debate is about somebody's age it's
actually about have they still got it
yep and I'm sure I would do this but I
still think that we have a society where
for one reason or another the old have
some key political decisions which they
think and they tend to vote their own
interests usually I mean obviously
pollution climate change
they say we all say oh our people might
well you know we're going to be all
right because we're going to be alive
and that's why I think when you look at
this you've got to say yes they are are
they mentally acute but you've also got
to say
um
are they hogging are they hogging the
intellectual framework yeah do you see
what I mean yeah I agree I think you've
got to have a younger more vibrant mind
really to run countries haven't you well
yeah and you know who knew that was Ken
Clark I mean Ken Clark stood down in
2019 when he was 79 he knew he was
getting a bit past it and it was time
for him to step back who's the oldest
Australian prime minister well it's
about you Paul pork was fantastic yeah
and he was no spring chicken was he no
he no he ran and again Paul Keating the
tree his treasure was hot on his tails
for the majority of his of his tenure
but I think you just even have to look
at someone like Jacinda ardern yeah as
well I think that's a different
generation of leader but I think one
thing maybe all Western democracy have
to look at is rather than allow these
people to sort of decay in front of us
have a mentorship program like imagine
having you know Biden bringing someone
up I know well actually I tell you who
had a good idea Nikki Haley who's one of
the Republican candidates for president
uh she actually did come up with an idea
I think we've got the clip
let's play this the America I see the
permanent politician will finally retire
we'll have term limits for congress and
mandatory mental competency tests for
politicians over 75 years old
now I'd see nothing wrong with that
particularly when you see that Joe Biden
only on Tuesday said this about the
number of Americans who died from covid
and they're still we're still feeling
the profound loss of the pandemic as I
mentioned we have over 100 people dead
that's 100 empty chairs around the
kitchen table
what are you talking about a hundred
Empty Chairs
what are you talking about you're the
president of the United States He
repeated it twice he got that wrong so
that's my point I think she's onto
something Nikki here to give them all a
test well we have it in Australia if you
are over the age of
um I think it's 80 or maybe even younger
74 you have to have a driving test every
year right so yeah it checks out yeah do
you actually have to do that here but
this is
I'm going to toss in a note of caution
here now I see it coming down the road
actually people are going to say well
you sure that you're already up to
driving and so on and so forth and all
the oldies ought to have a test I think
that's pretty tricky because if you look
at demographically that like eight
million people who are over 18. but
again what I would say again if Mick
Jagger is driving the car I'm fine with
it if Joe Biden's driving me I am
getting out the car what about Trump
then because that's the Dilemma odd
Trump oddly despite his 77 I think he is
now he's oddly very physically fit he's
never had a drink in his life never had
a cigarette never taken drugs
every week is genuinely a pretty fit guy
because he's never polluted his body
oddly that's an odd thing about all of
the burgers from McDonald's I mean that
was you know when I was on Air Force One
just playing a little name job there
when I was on Air Force One he had the
lunch was like something with kale in it
I couldn't believe it because you were
there
the very sad death of Sinead O'Connor
yeah so we talked about this yesterday
and Morrissey came out a lot of tributes
came out yesterday and Morrissey came
out and he was Furious he said you
praise her now only because it's too
late he tweeted you haven't you didn't
have the guts to support her when she
was alive and she was looking for you
who cared enough to save Judy Garland
Whitney Houston Amy Winehouse Marilyn
Monroe Billie Holiday where do you go
when death can be the best outcome was
this music Madness worth sinead's life
what think about this I mean it's got
it's a good point the problem with
social media and I listened as much as
anybody else somebody famous dies if you
know them you immediately pay tribute to
them but Chennai was clearly very
troubled had a lot of issues and the
music industry basically tossed her away
that's really the point he's making as
they did with all these people yeah and
we're seeing it in real time now I can't
believe like someone like our generation
we watched what happened to Britney
Spears like well I was a fan growing up
and then we see it all happen all over
again where is the say Britney crowd now
where you know she's making you know
questionable decisions about her life
and everyone the same narrative comes
down like clearly she's not she's not
well so rather than help her they
Pillager yeah I agree look I'm very much
of the belief that the Press sort of
hound people into you know positions
where they just cannot function anymore
and I think what was done to Sinead over
her life was abominable but I mean I'm
not going to sit here and take a lesson
from Morrissey because Morrissey is the
sort of person who wants to make it all
about himself all of the time he's the
sort of person who called Chinese people
subhuman you know he also said that
Diane Abba wouldn't even be hired by
Tesco I'm just like plucking a couple of
things that he said said I just don't
think that he is the morality police
right right message wrong messenger
Stanley do you ever know who Morrissey
is uh well
[Laughter]
come on
I know a film star who was called
Morrissey because I I read a novel and
he starred in the in in the film with
the book and so did John Hurt So to that
extent but well that's the same it's not
the same way it's not the same way let's
let's move on to Cricket
um
obviously I've been pretty outspoken
um despite being the show airing Oscar
is Australia I've been very outspoken on
behalf of my country in the ashes as you
do sped a good pommy to be this is how
the the Australian media have responded
to me
[Music]
so with the ashes in the bag everybody's
happy right no with Murdoch's winter in
Chief Piers Mormon crying foul on
Twitter uh sorry X saying it's an
absolute fast what a pig
the only time I'm ever serious about
Piers Morgan is whether I can just kick
him to death some way the shovel was
also laughing at Morgan's tears and the
Australians Peter Layla dubbed his
reaction as the whinge in the Willows a
classic English sob story
female journalist in Australia actually
said she wanted to kick me to death I
mean imagine if I said that about a
female journalist Australia like the one
we have here just for the record I don't
want to kick you to death Jenna okay uh
do you want to apologize about your vile
colleagues in the Australian Community I
want more I love this I think this is
the I think you know you guys have got
bazball how is that going for you we'll
get to that part later oh you've won
nothing yeah you've retained the ashes
because it rained you've actually won
nothing you haven't won the ashes I feel
like we talk about this post-truth world
and I I get it like Australians right we
identify like we won the ashes because
we won the Ashley you didn't win the
ashes you would change the ashes I've
got a Sally can you explain to anyone
who's a bit confused here the ashes have
been retained because they already held
them and we can't win them back in the
series but we could still draw the
series we we could draw the series we
certainly can't win the serves basically
it all went wrong when Johnny best when
they cheated they did cheat they don't
cheat I'm a chap walks out of his grease
he thinks the ball's dead yeah he's not
dead because someone throws it on the
umper now I think what ought to have
happened
captain or to withdrawal Auto withdrawal
by the way supposed to be this saintly
figure right brought in after sandpaper
gate where they did all cheat I mean
even you wouldn't just do that and then
they're at it again and he had one
chance to redeem the nation one chance
to redeem that team of sandpaper cheats
but no no instead he let him walk off
you love because it's like someone like
Paddy Cummings and I'm sorry I'm sorry
that he is kind of like the the Kate
Middleton to Cricket he is perfect in
every way he's upstanding he's the moral
police for the Australian athletes and
things like that you don't know how to
handle him so that's the only the only
fault you can pick yeah there's
something with Australians in actually I
love Australia I love Australia in an
ashes series they are absolutely
unbearable man woman we're talking
cricket if we're talking this summer
what was absolutely extraordinary was
there's eight sixes which are in the
second test yeah
unbelievable yeah and we're going to win
this test it'd be too all they're one
nothing you take the ashes but actually
there she's always standing there anyway
that's the unknown thing about this the
real one stay with us as it should be
lovely to see you thank you come back
soon uh lovely to see you
been talking about I'm not asking you
about it
I saw your incredibly blank face
literally no point asking you about it
absolutely great to see you lovely to be
here I'll say something next where is
the line to free speech and hate speech
and who should get to decide it well
Paul Davis may have crossed that line
this week and she'll debate this with me
live next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh Paul Davis is
the soul-styled anti-feminist influencer
who's creating major Buzz online with a
contrarian view she's appeared in a
couple of debates on this show it's
called uncensored after all we welcome
any honestly held opinions but this week
she's facing a major backlash of posting
a song titled why can't we talk about
the Jews which she dedicated to
far-right commentator Nick Fuentes we've
all later deleting it
why can't we talk about the
without getting kicked off of YouTube
now I'm not saying Hitler was a good guy
[Music]
but I kind of Wanna Know
why
now there's all these conspiracy
theories
and the more they talk I think maybe
they're right
but I can't even listen to the convo
well Paul joins me now along with the
New York uh author and founder of Ender
Jew hatred Brook Goldstein over in the
states all right Paul you've come on the
show a couple of times right we've had
some spirited debates about feminism and
stuff like that and I thought you've
made some good points and he's got lots
of traction then I wake up the other day
and I see this thing that's trending
involving you doing this song
and I could really believe what I was
watching I didn't know why why did you
find me very funny
huh did you find you find it funny I
mean you know the backlash today I mean
you you deleted it you obviously thought
you shouldn't have posted it why did you
do that
genuine question I mean the point was
more about cancel culture and people
getting kicked off of social media if
you finish the song it was more about
like you can't talk about this topic
without being canceled by the left and
the right I don't really have a strong
opinion either way it was kind of just
like tongue-in-cheek
um I didn't really expect it to get that
crazy
um I also it wasn't dedicated to anyone
I don't know why they say that but
that's not true I mean neat Fuentes is a
white supremacist he's a holocaust
denier uh he said afterwards that you
had dropped a diss track on the Jews
um which he clearly took to be something
which was you know mocking Jewish people
talking about I'm not saying Hitler was
a good guy but I want to know why what
do you want to know why well it was more
like why can't we talk about it it
wasn't like we talked about the more
conspiracy theories you've heard about
Hitler and the Holocaust Museum I'm a
fan of conspiracy theory like you know
people think I'm part of the CIA there's
a whole conspiracy thing online and you
know I'm not for like silencing it
either way the point of the song isn't
like I really have an opinion on the
matter it's more
I don't think we should ban people off
of social media so far so that I don't
even like I think it should be illegal
to ban anybody off of social media
unless they are inciting violence that
was the point of the song um I'm not
really
it was more like tongue but just to be
clear what are the conspiracy theories
surrounding Hitler which you feel I
don't know you hear them the more you're
interested in them well I don't know
because I can't hear them
I wasn't even talking about Nick I was
thinking of yay to be honest I don't
know why they put that Nick was the
inspiration for that song I was thinking
of yay you are aware of the big backlash
disease and the Deep upset from the
Jewish Community I certainly am now I
just posted that song and I woke up and
I was like article article article I was
like golly right but are you sorry crazy
um you know I I think that
like what it my whole point was that
cancel culture is wrong I am not
speaking one way or the other about the
issues my question is why are we
canceled about talk for talking about
certain topics so you would allow
Holocaust deniers to have space on
social media to promote Holocaust denial
to millions of people you have two
million people who subscribe to your
YouTube right that's a big audience of
people I'm not at 2 million yet I'd like
to be Robbie you have a lot of people
that follow you on the various social
media platform yeah you put a video like
that up and there are going to be some
impressional young ones going hang on
what's Pearl saying Adolf Hitler not
saying he's a good guy but I want to
know why the more conspiracies I I
theories I hear the more I have to think
about it but I took that to me I took
that to mean that you agree with it
why did you cut off the end of the end
of the song I said but we can't even
have the conversation what is the
conversation without being canceled
before the left and the right is
what is the conversation about Hitler
and conspiracy theories and the
Holocaust that you want to have I don't
want to have any conversation my Lane is
feminism that's what you're singing
about adults can I can I can I finish
you're singing about it okay okay you do
want to have that conversation I want
anybody that wants to speak on social
media to be able to speak about what
they want to talk about Judy Holocaust
without getting banned whatever they
want to talk about including Holocaust
to know if they want to talk about that
as long as they're not inciting violence
I think people also inciting violence
Jewish people
social media is the New Town Square
right you used to be able to go and say
your opinions in the Town Square now we
have corporations censoring what can and
cannot be said and I think that's wrong
I think that should be illegal let me
bring in Brooke good he's been listening
to this Brooke I don't think Pearl quite
understands why the wording of this song
which she deleted to be clear so
obviously realize this is not played out
maybe the way she hoped
um the offense is caused to the Jewish
Community why was it so offensive
well first first of all I want to thank
you for having me on and for
highlighting this issue not necessarily
highlighting Pearl but highlighting the
issue that what you pointed out is that
we're really facing a crisis of societal
conscious where someone like Pearl who
engages in hate speech and actually the
irony is she's complaining about being
canceled and yet she's on your platform
she has millions of viewers on the
internet and on social media and she's
complaining about being canceled the
crisis is that this is what is
profitable now this click bait this type
of racial incitement is profitable on
the internet and you know I'm sitting
here I'm listening to Pearl I don't know
if she's just plain stupid or she's
actually quite intelligent and knows
that what she's doing is so Sensational
that is going to make her a lot of money
but I want to say one thing Pearl will
disappear she will disappear like many
others before her because this is
something that's just a moment in time
she's like a train wreck it's like a car
crash you know for example you can't you
know you shouldn't be looking at it but
you can't take your eyes off it but I
want to make one more point I think it's
so important especially on this platform
hatred is taught nobody is born like
this and I talk about it a lot in my
book about the dangers of hate education
and it's not something that we can
debate that we can engage in a rational
argument with you can see what her
opinions are she thinks women shouldn't
vote women shouldn't have the right to
divorce he thinks that women should be
able to work she says these no it
doesn't say crazy things
rational please don't interrupt there's
no rational argument with someone like
this and this is a mistake that my
community makes the Jewish Community
very often that they think they can
bring facts to the table that they can
debate somebody like Pearl and it's you
know you're gonna get there you're not
gonna get any work you're going to get
Somewhere Only by shedding the light on
this type of bigotry to expose
I would let me just offer you some
advice right because I don't think
you're stupid and in the two appearances
you've made previously on this program I
thought it was it was interesting it was
controversial in some ways but actually
a lot of people would have agreed with
some of the things he was saying there's
no question about that but you seem to
know where the line was someone like
Nick Fuentes doesn't know where the line
is someone like Kanye West who I
interviewed after he went on some weird
anti-semitic Trope nonsense technique's
been wiped out by what he did well what
he said about the Jewish people because
there are certain things where I am
absolutely in support of the concept of
free speech right but you can't go
around telling Jewish people the
Holocaust didn't happen as the renters
Fuentes does say things like that but
I'm not I'm I'm not him
song right and you talk about who
determines what the line is Pierce who
determines
I'm asking you who gets to determine you
to work out in your head I'm saying that
you're not a stupid person when you say
I'm not saying Hitler was a good guy but
I want to know why right when you talk
about the more conspiracy theories about
in my hair the more I'm like well that's
interesting I'm just like a Gog but even
now you don't seem to really grasp why
singing that and releasing it to
millions of people is incredibly
offensive to Jewish people foreign
I think at the end of the day at the end
of the day Pierce I don't think it's for
you to determine what speech should be
allowed what about you determine why did
you delete it why did I delete it
because it was just a headache Fierce
because you knew it was wrong it's it's
I just think it's it's like
it's not the hill I'm trying to die on
right but why did you choose that hill
to dial I didn't choose this hill to die
dude you released That You released the
video I also released 10 different
videos about it but they're not all
basically but they're not talking about
Adolf Hitler are they are we not allowed
to talk about him we could talk about
hitting the right to the point you say
the more conspiracy there is a hear
about him look at I think that anyone
should be allowed to speak about any
conspiracy theory on social media that
is my point it's not about Hitler it's
not if you really believe what you did
wasn't wrong you wouldn't have deleted
it oh wow okay don't you think I I agree
with pearl
go on bro
if I may just say one one thing as an
attorney I have to say that I I do agree
with her that I am a free speech purist
and I think that even bigotry should uh
be able to be spoken in in the public
sphere but the problem of canceled
culture is not against
anti-jewish speech I think that's very
clear we see the scourge of
anti-Semitism and Jew hatred Rising on
the internet the problem is that there's
no consequences for it and the way that
private how are there no consequences
canceling is they're going after
pro-jewish speech they're going after
pro-israel speech I can't tell you how
many times I'm contacted by people and
often my own clients who are shut down
on social media for saying anything
positive about Jewish people about
Judaism or about Israel yet these social
media companies are unequally applying
their own standards and you know while
they're for example shutting down
coveted deniers they are allowing
Holocaust denial speech they are
allowing people like Pearl to spew her
hatred so if we are really free speech
purists and that's what we are I
understand that companies they should
allow all speakers yeah I I hear listen
I I would just say this to you unless
it's incitement to immediate violence
right I would say it's Depot so we agree
well I would say this to you in
conclusion on the same team now in
conclusion look you deleted this so you
clearly felt bad about what you'd put up
or you wouldn't have deleted it you
accept that no you don't accept it I
just you know it's kind of a headache I
was like well it just seems like a lot
of headache to me right or did you
realize actually in that moment from the
visceral reaction from the Jewish
Community you crossed a line a line that
you yourself should have worked out was
there look at the end of the day pierce
the song was about freedom of speech it
wasn't one way or the other the song was
about why can't we have these
conversations on social media and why do
I keep getting maybe a good one why do I
keep seeing people get banned on social
media my point is I I don't think there
should be a line unless you're inciting
violence
would we agree on that listen yes or no
no yes or no do you agree he's my no no
you haven't answered my question okay
I'm not saying Hitler was a good guy but
I want to know why I want to know why
what we can't have the conversation
without being canceled by the left and
the right I just don't understand the
conversation you guys cut out wait a
minute oh you did 30. okay the
conversation about whether Hitler was a
good guy you want to have that
conversation I think that he might have
12 million people getting six million
jobs
my whole point is we should be able to
have that conversation but whether he's
a good guy yes because it causes more
commotion when you're starting to censor
people I don't know I think that's wrong
to censor anybody well you know what you
can have that conversation you had that
conversation you posted it you haven't
been canceled I've had you on the show
because I thought you might with time to
think about this regret what you did
because you can clearly you're not
stupid you do understand the offense it
caused and wanting to have the right to
debate whether Hitler's a good guy is
just crazy no no I want anybody to be
able to speak on any platform that was
the point of the song
all right let's leave it can I point out
a Nuance here I've got a book I'm sorry
we want to run out of time but thank you
for coming on the program I greatly
appreciate it and Paul uh thank you for
coming on I appreciate it on sense of
next the supporters say it's a vital way
to teach tolerance in schools critics
say it's akin to segregation other
debate about the controversial movements
between schools critical race Theory
what's next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
these mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
Kinfolk do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Pete Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
whoop me off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that
you'd be worried about so are you saying
that you're being overwhelmed that
you're inundated we are really working
hard for you we're just asking patients
to be patient with us what does a woman
make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
teaches that racism is ingrained in all
aspects of society like a lot of radical
ideas that began in American
universities reach schools now spreads
to Britain here we tend to call it
institutional racism with everything
from the police to justice system or
even the countryside deemed
fundamentally racist Advocates of a
theory say it needs to be taught in
schools well the Pyramid of white
supremacy was recently used in a primary
school lesson by the church of England
it claims a casual racism can lead to a
path of violence and mass murder but is
it actually true or is it made up on a
false pretext joining me now has
contributed to Paula wrote Adrian and
the academic Chris Ruffo in America
whose new book America's cultural
revolution today throughout the New York
Times bestseller list so congratulations
to you Chris on that
um just for those who are a bit confused
in simple terms what is critical race
Theory
sure critical race theory is an academic
discipline that holds that the United
States is a systemically racist nation
and that all of America's institutions
from the Declaration of Independence to
our system of laws to our economy preach
the values of Liberty and equality but
in practice mask a system of naked
racial domination it's a deeply
pessimistic philosophy that acknowledges
no racial progress in the country and
seeks to subvert the institutions in
favor of what some have described as a a
race-based system of redistribution the
suspension of First Amendment rights all
in the name of racial Equity okay Poland
you're not going to be surprised to hear
that before you answer here are 10
things that have been labeled
institutionally racist in the UK in
recent years the NHS the Avon and
Somerset police met police police
Scotland Great American police Sir Paul
McCartney is performing arts school the
city of York Lambeth Council the home
office of Countryside the UK's
University's cricket and architecture
okay so let me start with what I
understand the definition of critical
race theory is so critical race theory
was born out of legal academics who
looked at the issue of the social
construct of race because remember race
is a social construct
Genesis will tell us that sociologists
will tell us that and it unjust tries to
understand how racism is deployed within
institutions so it's not talking about
the individual being a racist but it's
trying to understand whether racist
policies exist it will look at the
criminal justice system it will look at
education and for example it could look
at schools it could look at me NHS any
large establishment that's what I
understand critical race Theory to be
Lindy all right Chris I want to play
this is some an interview idea with Noam
Chomsky actually when she actually
referenced you let's take a look at this
critical race theory is a slogan
invented by the right wing and the
person who invented it Christopher Ruffo
has been very open and Frank he says we
just use this as a way to refer to
everything we hate
like teaching American history like
teaching gender issues we hate that so
we'll call it critical race Theory
response to that Chris
well it's quite clear that uh Mr
chomsky's uh has slowed down in recent
years of course critical race Theory and
gender ideology are not related they're
totally distinct phenomenon but what I
think he's getting at is that I am a
conservative writer I'm also a
conservative activist I've worked with
policy makers such as Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis to restrict racial
pseudoscience in the curriculum to
restrict racial scapegoating in the
curriculum and so I'll make no apologies
about it I have a a political vision for
for these policies I oppose a critical
race Theory not just the very sweet
euphemisms that my fellow panelists was
saying but the actual nitty-gritty of
the discipline which is called uh for
the suspension of private property
rights the suspension of freedom of
speech this is a radical ideology that
is self-described by critical race
theorists as deriving from Marxism I
think it's no place in the public school
system we shouldn't be dividing our kids
against each other on the basis of race
it seems to me that the problem is if
you basically make a case as people are
trying to that almost everything in
society is institutionally racist I
think it lose power and impact there are
clearly some institutions where you can
see it laid bare but there are many
others I just feel it's slightly
exhausting it's like if everything turns
out to be a negative slang everything is
based on institutional racism we keep
looking back never looking forward I do
get Chris's point which is it's just
relentlessly negative there's no chance
for positivity it's just constantly
attacking the past the history and doing
it in a slanty way that makes a lot of
white people let's be honest feel why is
everyone calling us races all the time
and I think that's the message that I
really wanted to get across at the
beginning that it's not about the
individual that's that's the first thing
I want to get across secondly the
impacts on our individuals feel well it
also impacts upon the victim as well
doesn't it the person who is suffering
due to the prejudicism the person who is
suffering due to the bias the person
who's suffering due to the racism Chris
referenced this as a pseudoscience we
need to be clear about this it's not a
pseudoscience it's never held itself out
to be a science of it's an academic
Theory and it's one that needs to be
discussed so that's the impressionable
Minds be are they the right people to
have these kind of quite complex
discussions
children at every level understand
unfairness they understand Injustice and
so it's important that that education
does form a part of their learning how
can it not they're going to see it on TV
they're going to see it on social media
they're going to see it within their
homes they're going to see it living
living through the spectrum of their
lives all right Chris just on that point
finally I mean kids they shouldn't be
completely protected from all racial
discussions so where is the line do you
think for educating kids about race
related issues yeah absolutely I mean we
should have a robust discussion about uh
race and public schools for example but
I've done reporting on dozens of public
schools in the United States and they're
separating kids by race having separate
training programs for teachers and
they're driving home this idea that if
you uh come from European ancestry that
you are inherently a racist that you are
benefiting from racial discrimination
and it's designed to to shame and
scapegoat individual kids and so when
you say it's not about the individual
then why are they drilling this into
individual kids heads that somehow
they're worse than others they should be
uh they should feel guilt they should
feel shame merely because of of their of
their ancestry that is political
propaganda we should not be pushing that
on schools and and furthermore as a
historical discipline if we want to call
it that critical race theory is is kind
of a far left conspiracy theory uh
critical Racers have argued that even
Abraham Lincoln was a deeply racist
person and advanced racism in the United
States this is a fringe theory that is
tolerated because people are
uncomfortable to push back luckily
that's changed I'm proud to be one of
the people that's changed that
conversation we're not going to be
bullied and intimidated by euphemisms
and soft talk we're going to put the
facts out there we're going to argue the
points and force our opponents the
critical race theorists to defend their
arguments on the substance
Chris rufo I'm Paula both thank you very
much indeed on since the next tonight
I'll take a deep dive into tick tock's
latest weirdest ever Trend ice cream is
so good find out what the hell I'm
talking about after break if I've worked
it out myself
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk Prince Harry's
plan to sue the Sun newspaper thrown
into turmoil where the judge rejecting
most of his claims the boss of Coots
calls it quits following the Nigel
farage Bank Scandal and kissed armor
finally accepts that a woman
is a woman that's all at nine
[Music]
welcome back to Piers organizer this is
a social media Trend so bizarre I'm not
even going to pretend that I understand
it but just take a look
it's my birthday
[Music]
hey hi yes the guy feel like a cowgirl
and you're ready
to New York Times and other media these
are grown adults performing as
non-playable characters they can make
thousands of dollars from fans who pay
to feed them digital treats or Pat them
on the head now Ted Talk is fun I like
pizza a massive on detail but is it
rotting our brains with this crap I'm
joined by Tick Tock star J Money the
host of Babylon B Ashley Claire well
welcome to both of you and talk to your
V presenter Rosanna Lockwood lurking to
fill in my seat after I go
um all right let's talk about this first
J Money sell this to me it looks
completely predators to me why is this
good and why is it so successful
um it's good and it's so successful
because it's it's the way to make money
just quickly just easily for people but
it's also fun
that was like fun train no I get it but
I mean people are telling you to do
stupid things and then you do them for
money I mean it is a bit like low rent
low level stuff I mean you're licking
your tongue you're licking the screen
it's like it's just weird isn't it
um
I am a cosplayer so I cosplayed on my
tick tocks
um when I first started so it's not as
weird to me okay so it was definitely
something fun and something good for my
like my personality okay uh Ash is a
glare look it's a bit of harmless fun
it's the kind of tick tock generation
love it why are we being such terrible
killjoys
I don't know that it's really harmless
fun I think in a
go ahead and think in a way and you I
unders I understand that some people you
know they're making good money and
that's appealing but in a way you're
selling your soul to this quasi-soft
core sex app in a way it's being
fetishized you're telling young girls
that have aspirations to be engineers
and other aspirations that they can make
quick money on Tick Tock which is owned
by bite dance and by proxy the CCP that
this is the way to make money this is
what you should do
I mean look there is a point there Jay
isn't it I mean I hear that argument but
then I guess my you know young people
will be watching this game listen you
old fuddy duddy you just don't get it
um definitely but um most kids do not
know or people do not know that it's
even a fetish so when we hopped on this
train it was just something fun it's
just something to do like every other
dance that is done on Tick Tock it was a
trend it was nice it was cool it was fun
people made it
something too serious everybody wants to
put their opinion in their own mindset
on things and kind of deliver a
different message than what people are
really intending it to be which is just
fun and something to make a little extra
money actually you had a little go at
this we've got a clip of you in action I
think
ice cream's so good yummy hot dog gg gg
thank you for the likes
ice cream's so good
I'm watching that thank you maybe I'm in
the wrong wrong game I should be doing
stuff like this for money
you know it's to be clear obviously that
was cropped and the rest the rest of the
video I was talking about BlackRock and
you know engaging in some of the infosec
war but I think Jay especially you you
have a lot of followers I think there's
some responsibility to be a role model
especially to these young girls here and
I understand that it's easy money but at
the end of the day your money is
dependent on an algorithm that is run
and created by people who are
ontologically evil the CCP and bite
dance and your views and your money is
now dependent on performing for that
algorithm on creating content for that
algorithm okay listen I've got to leave
it with you two uh We've run out of time
thank you both very much indeed
interesting debate about something I
knew nothing about let's bring in
Rosanna you've got the thankless task of
trying to replace me for the next few
weeks while I go and landra palm tree
um honor to be your last hurray this
kind of thing I mean am I just too old
it's you're asking the right questions I
think what does this lead Society too
but it is fun come on ice cream's so
good ice cream's so good it is very
addictive viewing and it's an honest way
to make some cash it's not only fat and
it's not that I've got anything against
that either but it's it's it's it's
pretty harmless well talking of harmless
fun let's bring in the graphic I think
we've got what we've got behind me a
little palm trees but there we go there
we go I don't like it and you've been
basically ramming down your Instagram
pictures of yourself on various beaches
around the world in the last couple of
weeks and I now intend to go off and do
exactly the same to you so you can be
looking forward to pictures of me lying
on hammocks under palm trees while you
slave away at the Piers Morgan
uncensored toll face good luck to you
Rosanna thank you peers honor to
declavering you again enjoy your holiday
take care that's it from me I'll be back
in a few weeks time rosanna's in the hot
seat she'll keep it on sense and you
keep it uncensored that's it good night
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Peters Morgan
uncensored in New York City King peers
and King Cube I think it's only one for
one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just cause
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for at what appear
an abuse of power
when they first got together there were
press stories way TK team that would
make her a
praying the man
Elaine Maxwell agreed to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic